[Music]
you're watching American history TV all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3 to
join the conversation like us on
facebook at c-span history
up next on the presidency journalist
Paul Brandis discusses his book under
this roof the White House and the
presidency 21 presidents 21 rooms 21
inside stories he explains how
presidents from George Washington to
Barack Obama have left their imprint on
the Executive Mansion we'll hear about
Thomas Jefferson's bathrooms Abraham
Lincoln's war office and JFK's Situation
Room the National Library for the Study
of George Washington at Mount Vernon
hosted this hour-long program
okay good evening everybody
my name is Doug Bradburn I'm the
director of the Washington library here
at Mount Vernon and it's my great
delight to welcome you to one of our
Ford evening book talks I'd also like to
welcome the c-span audience who is here
as well and everyone watching live
online all 10 of you I'm sure thousands
of thousands of you of course the Ford
evening book talk is a way really to
bring authors to the Mount Vernon
community free every month and we try to
bring relevant books and important
history topics as well and we have a
great one for you this evening it's
funded by Ford
Mount Vernon has had a long relationship
with the Ford family with the Ford Motor
Company going back to Henry Ford's
original donation of the fire engine
which helped keep the mansion safe Mount
Vernon is continually interested in
making sure that the mansion is safe
from destructive fire and that's
important to us going forward I would of
course mentioned that this relationship
to Ford is crucial because the Mount
Vernon ladies Association which is owned
and operated George Washington's estate
since the 1850s has never taken any
government money we only accept money
from private patriotic people and
foundations and that allows us to
maintain the house for the public but it
is a continual challenge going forward
now tonight we have an extremely
exciting speaker Paul Brandis who's
going to talk about his wonderful book
tonight about histories of the White
House and different stories he's an
award-winning independent member of the
White House press corps who founded west
wing reports in 2009 he distributes
television radio and print content for
clients around the United States and
abroad he's also a Washington columnist
on economics and finance for market
watch for the week he moderates panels
for the magazine in Washington and
around the u.s. on topics like
cybersecurity energy in Europe's
economic crisis he's a frequent speaker
around the country before all sorts of
groups and he's known
is an innovator in social media
brandis's twitter account at West Wing
report has the biggest following amongst
all accredited members of the White
House press corps he won the shorty
award for best journalists on Twitter
sponsored by the night foundation he has
two hundred and forty six thousand
followers on his Twitter account and
when he started West Wing report it was
all the rage and followed by everybody
of note it's ranked as one of the most
influential political Twitter accounts
and I was talking to him earlier to Paul
earlier and I said I'm right on your
heels Paul I've got four hundred
followers on my Twitter account so so
watch out but but when his account
West Wing report became all the rage
nobody knew well whose Western report
whose Western report it was like who's
Keyser söze who was running this massive
thing and tonight you'll get to see who
West ring report is it's Paul Paul
Brandes and we're delighted to have him
here with a career that spans across
network television Wall Street and
several years as a foreign correspondent
in Moscow he covered the collapse of the
Soviet Union for NBC radio and the
award-winning business and economics
program marketplace he's traveled over
53 countries on five continents that's
more than George Washington did I'll
give him that
at least that's tremendous and he's on
many boards of course as well one
factoid to give you he was part of an
investor capital group that purchased
the rights to the Russian rights to air
the Super Bowl for the National Football
League becoming the first person to show
the championship game in Russia I did
that by myself I did it all by myself
well as I'm gonna be the first person to
show the championship game on this
screen right here at the Rubenstein
which is which is also something to
point out so he's here tonight to talk
about his book under this roof the White
House in the presidency 21 presidents 20
rooms 21 inside stories
he's jumping the gun because I have one
more thing to say but here at Mount
Vernon we know the importance of telling
stories about houses and the things that
go on in them and how much they matter
to understanding the sweep
history the white house is arguably more
well-known than Mount Vernon and many
great things have happened there and
nobody brings them to life better than
Paul Brandis please everybody give him a
big Mount Vernon welcome okay that's the
one well thank you right boy that guy's
had a lot of jobs listening to that
introduction well what an honor to speak
at Mount Vernon I'm very appreciative
and before we start just a thank you
Doug Bradburn for that introduction just
just wonderful also I wanted to just
thank you to mark st. Angela's mark in
the room tonight by the way oh did he
bail out okay I was in the back room
thank you Mark is the the Chief
Librarian here and also was Steven
McLeod the director of library program
so my thanks and appreciation to all of
you so you know there are a lot of books
about the presidents lots of books about
the issues and the events that they've
been involved with over the past two
hundred and twenty years or two hundred
forty years I wanted to add a third
layer to that and that's the White House
itself how the building has changed over
the years and my theme is that changes
to that building that reflect the
history of America itself so I'm going
to break this talk down into two areas
or too many stories to tell here but
first I'm going to give sort of a quick
overview of how the White House expanded
how new technology came in and I'm going
to share with you a couple of stories
which I hope will be new to you
so let's start out by the way that
pointing out let's see if this thing
works here oh it does pointing out that
you know we Americans we like to think
of our country as a pretty young country
and in the overall scheme of things 240
years or so is not that old but when you
think about it the White House is
actually the one of the old
just continuous residences for head of
state in the world I don't know what
happened to the numbers here but
presidents have lived in the White House
longer than kings and queens and
Buckingham Palace it's true
longer than Emperor's have lived in
Tokyo's imperial palace that's this one
even longer than the one of my old
stomping grounds Moscow the Kremlin here
which became the Russian capital for the
second time only in 1918 when Lenin
moved them back from saint-petersburg so
the White House really for a young
country has quite an old history of
course there's one gentleman who never
lived there George Washington of course
but he picked the winning design for the
mansion it was submitted by the Irish
architect James Hoban and tragically mr.
Washington I died about a year before
John Adams first moved in construction
of the White House took 8 years this is
what it looked like this is a wonderful
painting by the way by Peter Waddell for
the White House historical get on your
way
for the White House Historical
Association and you can see the basic
contours of the building taking shape
this back here is the what is now the
South Lawn looking out the south side
and over there would be today's
Lafayette Square and Roosevelt Island
off in the distance and so forth what a
wonderful painting that is anyway the
the construction took 8 years it cost
two hundred and thirty two thousand
dollars that's about a seventy two
million dollars today I did the math on
that 72 million dollars and by the way
the real estate website Zillow today now
says that it would be a pray not that
it's on the market three hundred ninety
three million dollars that's sort of
what the ad would look like in the paper
at the prime location 18 acres and all
that I hear the amenities are pretty
good too
there's going to be a new tenant
apparently in about a year or so I'm not
quite sure who that's going to be but
they'll get a four-year lease and if we
like them maybe extend their lease for
another four years or so anyway when
soin Adams moved in it was November the
first 1800 and this is what it looked
like this would be the South Lawn here
and at the time if he noticed there was
no North Portico no South portico those
would not be added for another quarter
century ago so these steps at the time
again this is 1800 this was the
principal entrance to the White House
going back on the South Lawn this is the
north entrance here so that is basically
what John Adams saw when he moved in and
he was quite pleased and on his first
full day in the White House it was
November the 2nd 1800 he wrote Abigail
who was still back home in Massachusetts
he wrote her a letter and in it added
what amounted to sort of a benediction
of sorts for the building and in fact
that's where I got the title for the
book and what Adams said was I pray at a
heaven the best of blessings on this
house and all that shall hereafter
inhabit it may none but honest and wise
men ever rule under this roof and that's
the title of the book
dirty presidents later Franklin
Roosevelt was so moved by those words
that kind of disappeared for a little
while and FDR found that phrase when he
came into the White House and he
actually ordered them carved into the
mantle above the fireplace in the state
dining room a lot of you I know have
been in the White House when you go in
the State Dining Room this is what it
actually looks like carved there by
Franklin Roosevelt of course Adams did
not last long he lost the election of
1800 to Thomas Jefferson and when he
moved in Jefferson of course being the
architect that he was made some changes
one was to add pavilions which
eventually became today's East and West
wing's the famous colonnade
of course that you see the president
walking down Jefferson also is really
fastidious and at the time I don't know
how John Adams put up with us but at the
time the bathrooms were really just
outhouses out back and the President of
the United States John Adams used to run
out in the back to the outhouse and
that's what he did well Thomas Jefferson
is very fastidious man and he thought
that says this is not dignified for
presidents so what Jefferson did was he
actually added the first to what they
called water closets at the time he
built a reservoir on the top of the
White House that collected the rainwater
and that's how they flushed these of
these water closets so big improvement
Jefferson also changed the main entrance
to the Northside he didn't like the
south entrance that I showed you
previously so this became the principal
entrance to the White House and again
this looks very familiar the famous
Palladian window above the door carved
by these Scottish stonemasons I waste no
opportunity to promote Scotland that's
who the carvers were for that Jefferson
also made an extra change this is a
modern floor plan of the state floor but
what Jefferson did what is today's state
dining room here he actually made that
into his office
Jefferson's offices on the state floor
this goes back again looking out on the
South Lawn that's the north side that
was the main entrance so that was Thomas
Jefferson's office which is today the
state dining room and this is what his
office looked like again this is one of
the Peter Waddell paintings for the
White House historical associations I'm
going to come over here for a second and
show you what Jefferson did of course he
was surrounded by all his books and his
gardening tools and his maps which you
might not know about Thomas Jefferson is
that he actually had a pet bird in the
White House a pet Mockingbird it's up
here in the upper right of the painting
and Jefferson just allowed it to fly
about the room and sometimes Jefferson
in fact will actually feed his bird out
of his
own lips he had a train and the bird
would sit on Jefferson's hand or
whatever and and feed the bird so just a
wonderful painting by you by Peter
Waddell the painting also shows
Jefferson meeting with one of his
closest assistants by the way and one of
his best friends that is Meriwether
Lewis of Lewis and Clark
Sam Jefferson recruited Meriwether Lewis
who is from his area of Virginia and
Lewis was an officer in the army and
Jefferson offered him a chance to come
and work for him and Jefferson actually
go back to the floor plan for a second
what Jefferson did is he actually let
Meriwether Lewis live in what is today's
East Room on the south side there he had
sort of sailcloth from a sailing ship
and he partitioned off two small rooms
one was his bedchamber and the other was
sort of a small working space and
Jefferson of course was a winner where
Martha died in 1782 so Jefferson and
Lewis would sort of go back and forth
all day long down the famous cross hall
and work together they took a lot of
their meals together and they also
plotted what turned out to be in fact
the crowning achievement of the
Jefferson administration which of course
was the Louisiana Purchase so let's jump
ahead about a decade now to Dolly
Madison we were just talking about her
earlier today she is such a fascinating
first lady one of my favorites may Dolly
Madison it was just a wonderful first
lady
everybody loved Dolly Madison she was
outgoing she was vivacious held tons of
parties and everybody everybody wanted
invitation to the White House when the
Madison's were in power not so much
because of James Madison but because of
Donnelly everybody had wanted everybody
wanted to meet dolly and she knew how to
throw a party the food and the booze
were top-shelf
she served a popular new dish that was
all the rage it was called ice cream
a lot of her entertaining took place in
what is today the Blue Room she had a
different color preference as you can
see he was red in her day this is
another painting by Peter Waddell all
this of course went up in flames when
the British came to town in 1814 and
think that story is pretty well known
it's common knowledge I think that dolly
saved what was then and still now the
most famous piece of artwork in the
White House and that of course is the
famous Gilbert Stuart portrait of George
Washington and hangs today in the East
Room and it's not your average sized
painting by the way it's about two eight
feet by five so it's probably have the
size of this screen you think and it's
gigantic
and even though she knew the British
were coming she refused to leave until
that painting was saved she said I'm not
leading the president was off at the
front by the way so it was just her and
a couple of assistants tried to take the
painting down turns out the frame was
actually bolted to the wall so they
couldn't take it down so what they did
was they took a hatchet and they hacked
away at the frame and they took the
painting down lay it on the floor and it
was only then that she left so truly
courageous on her part and one of our
greatest first ladies I think I think
they named some snack cakes after her
too little
little later on I hope to get royalties
the then there's a story of the
president by the way who was nearly
killed in the White House on his own
inauguration day if you couldn't believe
it I'm talking about Andrew Jackson this
is one of the very few photos that we
have of Jackson it was taken in 1845
long after he left White House but just
a striking picture of him he died in
fact a couple of weeks after this was
taken but what happened during the when
he was nearly killed by the way there
was a wild inaugural party when he was
sworn in everybody came they're all
well-wishers at at one point Jackson who
was not at the best of health to begin
with he was crushed up against a wall
had trouble breathing and his aides had
to literally just push him through a
window and evacuate him to safety
probably the wildest party that's ever
been held at the White House that we
know of so there was a sort of early
well it might have been one I don't know
so those are sort of the first early
stages of the White House Jefferson's
adding of the first bathrooms was an
example of how the mansion grew and
adapted to changing times running water
came in under Jackson gaslighting during
the term of James K Polk
I'm going to talk about the Polk just
for a second this is a guy who we don't
think about very often but he was an
enormous Lee consequential president
probably the most consequential one-term
president I think we've ever had more
territory was added to the United States
during his four years than at any other
time much more than even the Louisiana
Purchase and Polk was a big believer in
technology during the Mexican American
War for example he used the Telegraph to
communicate with his commanders in
Mexico one of the first uses of
high-tech electronics in a wartime
setting very important and you know how
presidents today are criticized for
allegedly taking too much time off I
mean Bush all his time at the ranch and
Clinton sailing and doesn't
Obama play too much golf I think all
that is debatable because it's the most
stressful job in the world and I think
they deserve a little bit of but they're
human beings they deserve some time off
well this guy didn't take any time off
James Polk literally took a handful of
days off in his entire four years worked
his fingers to the bone micromanaged
everything to a ridiculously granular
degree and what did he do dropped out a
couple of weeks after leaving leaving
office so I think all presidents whether
it's again riding a horse playing golf
watching movies they deserve a little
bit of a downtime and we're going to
talk about the movies in just a few
minutes by the way
Polk was president by the way when the
first known picture of Whitehouse was
taken and here it is in 1846 now if you
see there's no balcony on the South
portico this is Howard look the South
the the balcony that we now know as the
Truman balcony would actually not be
built for another century ago until
Harry Truman after kind of a long nasty
fight so I went this balcony and he
actually got it but for most of its
history that is what the South portico
looked like let's jump ahead to where
this gentlemen I'm sorry that for some
reason on the screen this is a little
bit blurry but he needs no introduction
this is one of the most famous photos of
Abraham Lincoln it was taken by the
photographer Alexander Gardner just a
couple of weeks before Lincoln was
assassinated I think this was taken in
February 1865 and what I want to show
you now is that this photo has been
colorized look at this Abraham Lincoln
in the flesh which is just remarkable
and if you look at look at Lincoln's I'm
gonna pause on this for a second link it
was was there's such a powerful photo
Lincoln suffered from bouts of
depression the war was enormous ly
stressful one of his sons I'd died in
the middle of his presidency that the
war was just getting to him a and you
can see all of this in his face
look at the sadness in his his eyes and
again this was about two months before
his assassination a Lincoln like Polk
before him relied on the Telegraph as
well he was so impressed with the
Telegraph in fact that one day he got
the first coast-to-coast telegram it was
sent by the Chief Justice of California
Supreme Court and Lincoln was so
impressed by that that two days later he
ordered the federal government to
discontinue its use of the Pony Express
which was a really big deal at the time
it took 8 days to get Pony Express to
get something out to the to the west
coast of course the Telegraph it just
took a couple of a minute so Lincoln did
away with the Pony Express in a hurry
and it was this speed and this
technology in fact that helped him
manage the civil war if you've ever seen
the then Spielberg movie Lincoln sure a
lot of you have seen that it's very
authentic and in that film Daniel
day-lewis who plays the president spends
long hours in that room waiting for the
latest dispatches from his commanders
that is accurate so Lincoln as
commander-in-chief spent just a ton of
time in that room which was adjacent to
the White House by the way it was not in
the White House per se the use of
technology by the way it was mirrored by
other presidents and other president we
don't think of too often a Rutherford
Behe's this was a real hi-tech president
he was friends with Thomas Edison
Alexander Graham Bell and he and invited
them in fact to come to the White House
and display their wares knowing that the
attention that this would garner would
help those products kind of speed up
their entry into the marketplace so he
knew what he was doing in the White
House soon in fact got its first at
telephone you know the first number of
the first White House telephone by the
way you probably know the answer to this
the first number of the first White
House telephone was one that was the
number but not a lot of people could
call because there are only two or three
other phones in all of Washington at the
time
who's gonna it was gonna call I mean
there was a phone at the Treasury
Department next door and some I forget
who's some private citizen so I must
have been a friend of bells he had a
phone too so there might have been three
phones in all of Washington at that time
and if if you are one of the other two
guys the president actually answered the
phone himself sometimes which I'm pretty
sure does not happen today so I'm pretty
sure the president doesn't answer the
the function let me come back to the
second floor and to Lincoln for a second
because I want to tell you about one of
the great misunderstandings about him
and it concerns the so called and I say
that in quotes Lincoln Bedroom if you
see the arrow there that is what today
this is a current floor plan of the
second floor this is what today is
called the Lincoln Bedroom not so
actually in Lincoln's time this that was
his office and he called it the shop and
this is what his office looked like now
this room was really the nerve center of
the Lincoln presidency he met with his
cabinet here he wrote his speeches here
he issued the Emancipation Proclamation
everything happened in this room he had
maps on the wall where he could track
the Civil War and if you see the window
on the left he could look out onto the
mall
there's the unfinished Washington
Monument it's built about half where the
government ran out of money
imagine that government running out of
money so they just stopped during the
war the civil the the Washington
Monument construction actually stopped
and he could look beyond that cross the
mall across the river and depending on
how the war was going he could see
Confederate flags at at night sometimes
the campfires of the Confederate troops
in Virginia the enemy was often that
close just remarkable wartime conditions
for the president the enemy was really
just a couple of minutes away so that is
Lincoln's office today back then his
office relic back then and it was since
turned
into a bedroom by the Truman's this is
what it looks like today that's the
famous link in bed the Rosewood bed that
was purchased by Mary Lincoln oh that's
another misunderstanding Lincoln never
slept in that bed by the way there's no
evidence that he actually slept in the
Lincoln bad furniture is authentic but
he never slept in it so the question is
then if Lincoln didn't sleep in the bed
didn't slink sleep in the Lincoln
Bedroom well where did he sleep and the
answer is this is an authentic floor
plan of his era he actually slept down
here in the southwest corner where
presidents today sleep in fact that was
the president's bedroom his office as
you can see is on the other side of the
mansion Mary Lincoln had a separate
bedroom and the crush of visitors during
the the Civil War was so great that
really the first family their whole life
was just confined to just these couple
of rooms here and to ensure his privacy
and frankly also for reasons of security
Lincoln had this secret passageway built
that led to what is today yellow room
secret passageway that led to sort of
their living room I guess they called it
a library and and and that was it so
that was Lincoln's second floor during
his day
it's not just the Lincoln Bedroom by the
way but lots of rooms have actually
changed identity and purpose over the
years here's I'll just tell you one more
story about how these rooms change oops
ahead of myself here this is again
current second floor and with an arrow I
added the this is on the North Portico
north side of the White House rather and
if you see the second window from the
right that room today is the private
dining room of first families and
sometimes if I go into the White House
early in the morning I'll see the lights
on that's the first that's president's
private dining room right there and
sometimes you'll see kind of a shadowy
you know shadow or silhouette or
something of the wind you know they go
mrs. Obama's fixing yourself a cup of
coffee or something
here's President Ford sipping his
morning Oh Jay I think this is 1975 look
at that cool TV by the way remember
those TVs people used to have here's
Nancy Reagan on what was her last visit
to the White House this was 2009 the
Obamas invited her for lunch and that's
the private dining room but what people
don't know about this room it's today
the private dining room would put what
people don't know however is that this
room actually has a pretty morbid
history William Henry Harrison first
president dying office died in the room
in 1841 I mentioned Willie Lincoln one
of the presidents sons he died in that
room in 1862 Lincoln himself after his
assassination autopsy and embalming were
performed in that room that's obviously
not a that's a National Geographic
reproduction I just want to point that
out there are no photos here but a lot
of creepy things occurred in that room
and you wonder do the presidents when
they're eating breakfast or having
coffee I'm sure they're aware that that
room has kind of a rather morbid history
in fact it didn't really even become a
dining room at
the Kennedys moved in Jacqueline Kennedy
and by the way it's not Jacqueline
Kennedy she pronounced it Jacqueline
which according to Caroline Kennedy so
Jacqueline Kennedy wanted more privacy
for her two kids so she converted that
room which was bedroom into the private
kitchen this is what it looked like in
1963 the last year of Kennedy presidency
now as long as we're talking about the
Kennedys here that's the location of the
of the farewell prior to getting a
little ahead of myself the this was the
private dining room on the second floor
mrs. Kennedy did not like the fact that
they had to go downstairs to the State
floor to have their meal she thought was
just too cumbersome and too intrusive so
that's where the dining room on the
second floor came in now as long as
we're talking about the Kennedys
everybody knows of course about the
restoration efforts that mrs. Kennedy
made in 61 and 62 just as an aside Pat
Nixon did just as much never got credit
that she deserved I just want to point
that out but it's really the changes to
the West Wing that the Kennedys made
that I'm going to talk about here now we
know that three months into Kennedy's
term he had the worst humiliation of his
presidency it was the Bay of Pigs
in the aftermath of that the president
decided that he was not getting the
information he wanted quickly enough and
it wasn't the right information he
wanted his own set up two weeks later he
got something called the Situation Room
it used to be a bowling alley for Harry
Truman who played poker and never really
bold so they moved that to the old
executive office building and this is
what the first Situation Room looked
like looks like a early 60s suburban rec
room or something but but this is what
this is what John F Kennedy wanted and
it's what he guarded what he got it
enabled him to get the information he
wanted fast
without going through the channels at
the State Department and CIA and
Department of Defense he wanted raw
unfiltered fast information and that's
what he got
and the irony is that a year and a half
after the Bay of Pigs the Situation Room
actually played a really big role in
what was probably his greatest foreign
policy achievement and that was the
Cuban Missile Crisis of course where he
convinced Soviets to or removed their
missiles so the Situation Room actually
played a huge role in his presidency
simply for that reason Situation Room is
badly named by the way it's not this is
current floor plan it's not one room but
several rooms this is a below ground
there's the Oval Office one floor above
as you can see it's several rooms you
remember the famous bin Laden picture of
the night they got Obama photo the night
that got bin Laden it was that's where
that was taken so that's sort of what
President Kennedy did to the to the west
wing the other Kennedy story I find a
little creepy and actually concerns one
of the most documented covered discussed
events of the 20th century and yet a lot
of people don't really know that much
about it it concerns the Kennedy
assassination now I mentioned that mrs.
Kennedy redid the the mansion itself she
also wanted to redo the Oval Office
itself there's Caroline and Kerry
Kennedy I think one of the Robert
Kennedy's daughters playing there she
hated the green carpet and the drapes
which dated back to the Truman era and
she told President Kennedy I want to
redo your office too and he said fine
and she picked everything out the
workers told her that they both needed
to be away for about two days so they
could do the job and again this fall of
1963 and the only two days when they
would both be away happened to be the
third weekend in November when they went
to Texas so literally and I mean
literally as the President and mrs.
Kennedy made their way from Fort Worth
to Dallas
to get into the motorcade we know what
happened next workmen went into the Oval
they removed that famous resolute desk
they ripped up the green carpet and as
the president's motorcade as he went
from Fort Worth to Dallas that day they
put in the new carpet on the day of his
murder
in its color a deep blood red this photo
in fact was taken the afternoon of the
assassination this picture was taken on
November 22nd 1963 and at the time
daniel patrick moynihan who later went
on to become New York senator he was a
White House aide at the time he looked
in solve a new carpet and he said oh my
god it's as if they knew a new president
was coming and really a very morbid kind
of story mrs. Kennedy actually saw the
red carpet the next day for a few
minutes while her husband's casket lay
in the East Room she returned the White
House by the way just once over the rest
of her life it was simply too painful
for her so it's really stories about
stories like that that I tried to find
and put in the book they're just too
many to to talk about here and suggest
the Roosevelts and the Nixon's and this
picture in the upper right by the way is
a I took that one myself
of the first family look how young the
girls look I think that was in January
of 2010 when they came back from Hawaii
I think that's a more competent pictures
that have been taken by the way I
mentioned the the movie theater and this
is sort of last one of the last stories
I'm going to tell here the movie theater
is one of the truly great perks in the
White House here as president and mrs.
Reagan watching a movie Barack Obama
likes to throw a Super Bowl party this
is I think I think this was right after
he moved in in fact in 2009 it's really
one of the most coveted
invitations to watch a movie or anything
with with the president and here's what
I find interesting about the theater if
you look at records of what the
presidents have watched over the years
you know the tastes are obviously very
eclectic and everything and they reflect
the tastes of the presidents they
reflect the times in which they lived
and everything but there's one movie
this is a quiz section of our evening
here there's one movie that really
resonated with more presidents than any
other one can you guess what that one
movie might be it'll be obvious when I
explain it but can anybody guess what
well Patton was a Nixon film no question
about it but to everyone from Eisenhower
up to the present can anybody guess with
that gone with the wind was a good guess
but that's not it that's a good guess
too but that's wrong that would be that
would be that would be that would be
good no the one movie no the one movie
nobody ever nobody ever gets this the
one movie that really resonates with so
many presidents is High Noon Gary the
Gary Cooper Western great movie I know a
lot of you have have seen that Dwight
Eisenhower loved this movie so did
Ronald Reagan George W Bush loved this
movie both Bill Clinton claimed he saw
it 20 times I love this movie so
is that was that good there what what's
your name so it's really one of the few
movies that has resonated with a lot of
presidents and why high noon and the
reason is that if you know the plot of
that movie the bad guys are coming to
town the sheriff is all alone all his
friends have abandoned him it's up to
him to defend the town all by himself
and presidents can can can that that
resonates with with presidents sometimes
I feel like the burden is theirs alone
and then no one will will will help them
that to make life-and-death decisions on
their own and that's why in fact the
presidency is called the loneliest job
in the world and it's called so with
very good reason I think there are a ton
of other stories that I can tell you
here but I'm going to stop here and just
say thank you so much for inviting me
tonight and I really appreciate the
opportunity to speak to you
thank you and if anybody has any
questions feel free you guys with
somebody ever
oh oh by the way don't speak until you
actually have the microphone if you want
to be on television you'll have to
question anybody yes my Chad how much
has the footprint of the structure
changed since that burned down did they
rebuild it basically on the was it the
same architecture and they just built it
back up or how did it change well she's
talking about after the fire of 1814 the
outer shell of the White House was was
still there they read they built around
that it's the same footprint but of
course over the years it's expanded when
Ulysses Grant was president they
actually thought about moving the
president's house to bluff overlooking
Rock Creek Park they were this is right
after the Lincoln assassination there
were security concerns then of course in
the Truman era the White House literally
nearly collapsed the president and Bess
Truman gave Margaret a piano and one day
a leg of the piano actually fell through
the ceiling on the second floor and they
really thought is going to collapse they
had to move into Blair House for about
three and a half years while they they
they fixed it so interesting but basic
footprint is is still where it is except
of course the east and the west wings
have been expanded and of course it's
expanded deep below ground too and a lot
of secret ways yeah
any other question you've talked to
briefly about coming into the White
House very early in the morning and
seeing the dining room lights lit up can
you tell a little bit about what it's
like to have the job that you have and
what are some of the things that you
have found to be a pleasure in that job
as well as perhaps a burden well to me
the pleasure is really the for the
reason why I decided to write a book in
the first place is such a privilege to
go it's such a privilege and
you're enveloped by history when you go
in there I mean I was in the East Room
last week and I've been in there a
million times but when you go in there
here in the center of the room
this is where Lincoln's casket lay and
John F Kennedy and again there's a
famous Gilbert Stewart painting on the
wall it's where Gerald Ford was sworn in
after Nixon resigned just on a lesser
note Susan Ford had her prom there and
Amy Carter scuffed up the floor where
the rollers get just the history is just
remarkable and you simply can't escape
it it's just it's just remarkable when
you're walking where a Lincoln walked
and Thomas Jefferson walked and Franklin
Roosevelt rolled around it's just
amazing so that's really the yeah it's
just still mind-blowing to me to go in
there in the in the floor plan I think
it was of the current White House on the
second floor there was a room that was
noted as COS dot room
what is that room in the West Wing yeah
that would be the chief of staff office
yeah chief of staff was right it looked
like was right there in the private
areas oh my god
sure yes sir
this has been fascinating but I was
wondering if you covered the four
children because I've always heard the
rumor that the four children smoked
marijuana on the roof of the White House
or on the balcony when Ford was in the
White House I was I was just a wee lad
so I can't really speak I've those I've
heard that there's somebody in the room
I think you might comment on that but
I'm not gonna put him on the spot but
I've heard those stories and I've heard
about Jenna Bush doing it so what you
know so they're thick they're children
so yeah maybe maybe true any true yes
sir
can you get a microphone thank you
it's probably true can't prove it I was
interested to see that painting of the
White House under construction that
showed all the bricks among the various
rooms
we're told that during the complete
reconstruction of the White House in
1950 when they completely gutted it
Mount Vernon got the bricks and built
the slave quarters in the greenhouse
from those bricks from your reaction not
true that is true that is the case not
the entire structure wasn't from those
bricks but but those bricks were part of
what was used to build this type were
divided right that's correct you know
the sad part about that that's an
interesting question when the the
reconstruction 48 to 52 a Truman told
these guys just to hurry up get the job
done and as a result there's there's a
ton of debris from the building they
just dumped it into a giant landfill in
Virginia all kinds of but I don't know
bricks but oak wood and frames and just
it was just a huge waste Truman told him
to just cut corners and get the job done
so some landfill around here that has a
bunch of riches in it you know if you're
an archaeologist good project for you
that's a fascinating presentation thank
you but I have a question based on the
introduction of you what did the
Russians make of the superball how did
you explain it to them well the super
bowl question about is one of these
events but the you know when I was
living in Russia of the this is this is
how long ago it was the Redskins were a
good team that's how long ago okay and
at the year the year before our they won
the Super Bowl and I was working over
there by god I missed the Super Bowl
last time I'm gonna I'm gonna watch the
game next year and I actually figured
out that if I had some big screen TVs
and satellite feed I could make it
happen
there was a first western hotel there
there's a Radisson and actually cold
called the NFL from eight time zones
away and pitched them this said well if
you can come to New York and you know
convince us well you know we'll let you
do it and I wound up buying the rights
myself I wrote a check and then when I
came back and staged it and everything
and the Russians were I didn't know what
to make of it it was just a weird they
think they invented baseball too by the
way they do they didn't know what they
know what to make of it come on people I
told Paul that Mount Vernon has the best
questions for any speech there must be
something to ask the man I'll go ahead
okay gentleman here oh good well there
you go get that gentleman what's the
most interesting story about ulysses s
grant in the White House well grant I'm
not sure whether this is apocryphal or
not but grant one day got a speeding
ticket he had his civil war horses and
he had a buggy and he liked to go out on
rides around town and one day he was
speeding down I know what the road was
but he was going way too fast and a
Washington policeman told the president
overs by himself than this carriage and
he started to give the president a
ticket then he realized oh it's the
president and Grant said no no do your
job and give me as a $5.00 per ticket or
whatever it was and grant thanked him
and went back to the White House that's
one of my favorite grant Stewart's the
president you got a speeding ticket
while in the office doesn't happen today
I don't I don't think so yeah I had read
that Eleanor Roosevelt used to have all
kinds of people come in and stay at the
White House through over the time period
what was the wackiest one she had in
Eleanor Roosevelt
Ellen Roosevelt would sometimes just
invite total strangers she met on the
street to stay overnight in in the White
House and often they weren't enough
bedrooms to go around so I'm sure
hilarity ensued but that was what that
was what she did she was Rishi was a
real people person and she would just
service personnel and so forth and
sometimes just people she met she just
liked to talk to people and that's what
she did so she's a quite an interesting
character all right with Sally Hemings
on staff at the White House and the
Jefferson administration you're talking
about Jefferson's his mistress slave
with whom he it's believed he fathered
what I think about six children with her
I don't think I don't think she was I
I'm not I'm not sure I think she
probably stayed down at Monticello but
that's a good question don't know it's a
fifth question so one of my favorite
stories that you tell in the book
relates to Wilson they see the last
Virginian President Woodrow Wilson who
was right who got married to his second
wife and they had an interesting
relationship why don't you tell a little
bit of that story well Woodrow Wilson's
first wife died while he was in office
and he was very lonely and he wanted to
beat somebody else and he thought well
I'm never gonna meet any commute another
one I'm 53 years old or whatever he was
and about a month later in fact he saw a
woman on the street corner who happened
to be a friend of the person he was with
his personal position and introduction
was arranged her name was Edith Galt and
the president was smitten and they began
dating and the president to impress as
if isn't being President impressive
enough
it's present in the United States
impressive enough but what he did he
wanted to really impress her so what he
did was he shared top government secrets
with her which is a huge huge security
lapse and that's what he did I think
just being president is enough that
doesn't impress her then I don't know
but that's what he did and they wound up
getting married and during the first
world war
Edith in fact really interesting she
learned to code and decode secret
government messages so she went to work
is basically a clerk for the War
Department sending messages abroad and
and deciphering them and so forth very
interesting and then after Wilson got he
was severely crippled by he had a stroke
in October 1919 Nero killed him couldn't
speak couldn't move for a long time and
in one of the greatest cover-ups in
American history his wife the doctors
the White House staffers they completely
covered it up can you imagine that
happening today para president
absolutely paralyzed and they covered up
and she in fact took it upon herself to
do his job she looked at papers and
signed documents and decided what was
important and what was not this was all
kept hush-hush eventually people figured
it out when the president didn't appear
for weeks on end but they it was an
incredible cover-up and that's what that
sure claimed with him and I write about
that it's really one of the most under
under untold stories an under told story
that's just remarkable Edith Wilson
Paul you're a great storyteller I
remember you telling me a story one time
about a speed dial can you tell that
story the speed dial yeah you were going
through and you hit a particular button
on a phone and you've got a gentleman in
California his role that has nothing to
do with any of this but it's like the
Super Bowl where these questions came
from but it's not being recorded or
anything so don't worry about it well
the short of it is I wound up hanging up
on Ronald Reagan one time because no big
deal I was working for a thanks a lot
Jim I was I was working for a public
relations company still in business
despite this story and on the staff this
is after President Reagan left the White
House and he'd moved back to Bel Air and
on staff at this public relations
company was a woman named Sheila Tate
who was one of the president's former
assistants I'm sorry she was Nancy
Reagan's press secretary and one night
we were working some me and some other
guys were working late on a project as
you know eleven twelve o'clock at night
or something were getting a little loopy
and we just decided to take a break in
these offices had their doors and sheilo
the Sheila Tate's office and we went in
there and on the cheddar ego wall with a
Camp David in the Air Force one pictures
and everything and there's her rolodex
on her desk and somebody started looking
at it and and oh here's a private number
for president and Nancy Reagan and Bella
it's like don't can't possibly be their
private number and and I and on a dare I
wound up calling that number as
twenty-three twenty-four years a lot of
well did calling that number and I'm
thinking certainly that an assistant or
someone would would answer the phone
and then they picked up the phone and it
was this unmistakable I Cal
and and and and and we just and we and
we hightailed it out as a very innocuous
where I was I was certain I was certain
we were all going to get nothing ever
happened but it was it was so I well so
that's the time Thank You mr. Porter's
it's time I hung up on them on the
president's yeah it's up let's get one
last question to finish it off here no I
forgot about that that would go on the
neck book maybe hi it was an excellent
presentation thank you I haven't been to
the White House in over 40 years but now
I'm very interested in going would you
consider giving a behind-the-scenes tour
to a few I think I just did
the the the best way to get in there now
at some serious note I mean Security's
so so strict there now that the best way
is to go through your congressperson and
I think that process is rather laborious
now I think it starts about you have to
start about six weeks in advance and
give your social security number and all
of that I can't actually get people
beyond the the game I don't encourage
you to jump the fence by the way either
but if you can take if you can take the
tour you should it's just wonderful and
you will see the state floor that we
talked about the East Room its state
dining and we can see the atom has
benediction carved into the mantle and
the red blue and the green rooms and if
you're really lucky on the day you were
there when the president is coming or
going on marine one
they might take you out back and you can
stand there and watch the chopper come
and go which is really a real thrill to
watch so I hope you get to do that well
let's all give him a big round of
applause
thank you all so much for coming out
tonight a couple of administrative notes
his books are for sale right outside the
door behind you and we're gonna chain
him to that desk right there until he
signs all the things he can sign before
he leaves if we run up our stock of
books you can purchase them from us at
the same discounted rate and we'll ship
them to you for free but we have little
placards that he can sign as well so you
can have it personalized for you or
anyone it's a nice gift for Thanksgiving
coming up and also can you if you if you
like the book if you could get onto
Amazon and write a good review that
would be yeah that would be helpful
shameless plug all right thank you Paul
[Applause]
[Music]
you're watching American history TV all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3 to
join the conversation like us on
facebook at c-span history
Monday night on the communicators two
guests holding differing views on net
neutrality Walter McCormack president
and CEO of US telecom the company that
was the first to sue the FCC over its
rules on Internet service providers
which allow access to all content and
applications regardless of the source
and Christopher Lewis vice president for
government affairs at public knowledge
who supports the FCC's plan they're
joined by Alex Byers Politico technology
reporter what we objected to was the way
in which the FCC went about the open
internet standards it adopted them as
regulations pursuant to common carrier
Authority this is a 19th century form of
regulation originally applied to common
carriers like railroads trucking
companies and Airlines it has been
repealed for all of those traditional
common carriers and we don't think
common carrier regulation is the right
form of regulation for the 21st century
internet we're worried about consumers
you know that that's what drives us and
we don't want while we also while we
want consumers to be able to get the
best fielding week they can we also want
to make sure that everyone has access to
the great opportunities that the
internet offers and when you start to
see a two-tiered internet created
because of any competitive way that data
caps and zero rating is applied that
causes concern watch the communicators
Monday night at 8:00 Eastern on c-span
to
during campaign 2016 c-span takes you on
the road to the White House as we follow
the candidates on c-span c-span radio
and c-span
you
on December 16 1773 thousands of
Massachusetts colonists gathered at Old
South meeting house in Boston to discuss
a shipment of tea that had recently